let's get some perspective now on the
week from ed O'Keefe who covers Congress
for the Washington Post Ed's a familiar
face here as a CBS contributor and we're
very glad to say that starting next
month will be joining CBS News as a
political correspondent let's start off
by talking about this meeting between
President Trump and North Korea's Kim
jong-un yeah if this occurs it would
obviously be historic what are the risks
in a meeting Oh huge risks I mean like
arrow was saying I think the logistics
of this are gonna be the most
complicated part of this and then what
exactly would be discussed and and what
assurances are there that he would
follow through remember every other time
Americans have engaged the North Korean
regime in the last 2025 years they've
fallen back on their assurances of
promising to work with them so we'll see
you know but make no mistake this
announcement combined with all the other
things the president likes to announce
and do with great big fanfare it's just
consistent with that and whether or not
the follow-through actually happens I
think will be the biggest question you
know we've seen dramatic moves on
immigration gun control other issues
nothing's come of it we'll see if we get
anything out of this one as well and
like those issues his own administration
does not seem to be on the same page we
have the Secretary of State saying I'm
surprised
usually a meeting like this is the end
result of months if not years of careful
diplomatic negotiations I see precisely
so you know again consistent with what
this president has done before announced
it first sorted out the details later
make a big splash on television and he
did that and and we'll see whether or
not anything comes of it late in the
week the president said he would move
forward with steel and aluminum tariffs
a move that is he's gotten significant
pushback even from within his own party
on what are you hearing from the hill
about where that Stan big concern and
and you know there is still a chance
that later this month
in in what is probably going to be the
last big piece of legislation passed
this year before the elections the big
spending bill they might try to tuck in
some language that would either pull
that back or stop it from happening no
serious attempt at that so far but look
at those faces
speaker Ryan said I disagree with this
decision those are two words the speaker
has never used in almost anything that
this president has done her said Mitch
McConnell said I'm concerned John Thune
said this is causing chaos and confusion
again words we haven't heard from
Republican leaders in response to
anything this president has done shows
you how deeply worried they are about
this because anything that could
potentially upset that economic growth
could upset the Republican chances at
the polls in November this would seem to
split sort of trumps base off from the
Republican Party yes I mean there is
actually a fairly big difference here
because there are some Democrats that
actually like these tariffs in fact this
is a big wet kiss in essence this to a
bunch of moderate Democrats running in
industrial Midwest states who said this
is great and if I were the president I
do even more yeah so it just divides the
Republicans even more and and gives a
gift to some of these Democrats who need
something to be able to agree with the
President on ahead of November it
basically caused the president's own top
economic adviser Gary Cohen to leave the
administration we expected Gary Cohen to
go at some point this was certainly a
convenient excuse because he had been
making the argument not to do it and he
lost what are you hearing about a
replacement not much yet but you know
Peter Navarro who is this
this trade representative who's there
right now certainly now steps into a
more prominent role and interesting that
the president said Gary Cohen might come
back at some point but it would have to
be for a pretty good job another story
from this week stormy Daniels the adult
film actress has filed a lawsuit against
the president is raising some potential
red flags as far as election campaign
finance law what can you tell us about
that I think the important thing to
remember here is you know this will get
caught up in all of the ongoing
investigating by robert muller remember
this started with Russian interference
or potential collusion with the Trump
campaign it's going to lead to things
like stormy Daniels sounds a lot like
what happened to Bill Clinton it started
with a land deal in Arkansas it ended up
with Paula Jones and all these other
things and it just shows you that this
is a wide-reaching investigation that's
going to go in all sorts of different
directions they're gonna be concerns
about campaign finance violations and if
this non-disclosure gets tossed out in
court if she starts talking you wonder
where things will go
I'm sorry you're gonna say go ahead now
one last thing on this long list that we
have but we saw legislation passed in
Florida yeah gun control yeah is that
gonna change the landscape do you think
in midterms in terms of the importance
of this issue in this election well
we'll see I mean I think there could be
state legislators that either suffer or
benefit from this in Florida the legal
challenge that the NRA is now promising
I think could be a bigger test of this
over time because not only is the NRA
now challenging what Florida did there's
at least one guy out in Oregon who's
suing Dix and Walmart for implementing
their age limits as well so if these
court cases make their way through and
test potential limits on the second
amendment we may not get results on that
for a few years that could be even more
significant than than any electoral
changes in November and we need you to
clone six copies of yourself one for
each issue 17 years of dues
congratulations welcome to see ya